porque hay países ricos y países pobres
qué mérito tienen los que son ricos y
que han hecho los que son pobres para
serlo es una pregunta que siempre me ha
fascinado pero es que además es una
pregunta de gran interés porque en el
mundo actual los países se clasifican
según ricos y pobres todos los que son
pobres quisieran ser ricos
muy a menudo hay un efecto también
perverso la gente que vive en los países
ricos pueden mirar a la gente de los
países pobres por encima del hombro
mientras que aquellos que viven en
países pobres miran a los de los países
ricos con una cierta admiración con
envidia y muy a menudo con ganas de
marcharse y emigrar hacia ellos
pero realmente han hecho algo los
habitantes de los países ricos por serlo
y los de los países pobres por no serlo
desde luego los seres humanos somos
todos iguales y todos merecemos y
tenemos la misma dignidad por tanto no
podemos decir que haya humanos mejores o
humanos peores la prueba también está en
que cuando muy a menudo gente de países
pobres emigran a países ricos y se
integran sobre todo si son de culturas
parecidas y enseguida llegan a los
mismos niveles de efectividad y de
aportación a la sociedad como los
nativos
por tanto si no es la calidad humana
qué es
yo he vivido en muchos países europeos
básicamente algunos ricos y otros menos
desde hace 12 años vivo
en una ciudad que se llama timisoara en
rumania
que representa un poco el cambio o las
posibilidades que tienen también zonas
pobres para dejar la pobreza atrás y
hacerse mucho más ricas rumanía es un
país que vivió la dictadura de ceausescu
sufrió muchísimo y quedó al final de la
misma completamente destrozada
económicamente haya habido ha habido
zonas en rumanía pues que han prosperado
muchísimo desde entonces yo desde hace
seis años soy cónsul honorario de españa
en esta en esta ciudad
esto me ha permitido además por supuesto
conocer muy a fondo lo que es la
realidad de esta ciudad
'vamos y de este país vamos a ver en
primer lugar el mapa de europa este es
un mapa de las regiones de europa
cuanto más azul es la región más rica es
y cuanto más roja más pobre la región
pobreza o riqueza entendida como riqueza
por cápita per cápita es decir la
producción de riqueza de la zona
dividida entre el número de habitantes
se puede ver que hay una zona central
donde se concentra una gran parte de la
riqueza europea
es cierto que hay zonas muy poco
más alejadas del centro como puede ser
la península escandinavia que parecen
con colores muy azules
es curioso porque noruega por ejemplo
que actualmente es el país más rico del
mundo
si dividiremos la riqueza de noruega
entre los noruegos cada uno tendría en
el bolsillo un millón y medio de euros
por tanto noruega hace 50 años era un
país pobre hace 100 años los noruegos
emigraban todos a eeuu me podrán decir
si es cierto pero es que noruega se
descubrió mucho petróleo sí pero luego
tenemos otro ejemplo de un país como es
irlanda que hace 30 años era un país
pobre y hoy es un país rico también
emigraban los irlandeses eeuu pero ellos
no tienen petróleo que los ha hecho
ricos y luego sabemos que hay muchos
países en el mundo que tienen mucho
petróleo pero que en cambio viven en la
miseria por tanto vamos a dejar algunos
casos extremos como puede ser noruega
para centrarnos en la mayoría es muy
difícil establecer una regla general
pero sí que es interesante ver qué
criterio utiliza el banco mundial en
este caso para clasificar a los países
según ricos y pobres es muy sencillo
el primero de los criterios es
la riqueza natural
se considera que un país tiene más
posibilidades de ser rico si tiene
riqueza natural es decir con esa riqueza
que tenemos plantas lagos etcétera que
riqueza podemos producir en el futuro el
segundo criterio es la riqueza
industrial cuanto más industria podamos
tener más podremos más riqueza futura
podremos llegar a tener
el tercer criterio es la gente gente y
que esté bien preparada porque países
como bangladesh que tienen cientos de
millones de personas pero que están más
preparadas pues no figuran entre los
ricos en cambio países con menos gente
pero bien preparada sí que tiene una
capacidad de producción de riqueza muy
elevada en el futuro y el cuarto es un
criterio financiero en el que no vamos a
entrar supongo que se preguntarán cuál
de ellos es el primordial en el momento
actual porque eso ha ido cambiando en el
pasado la riqueza podría venir de la
tierra después de la industria pero hoy
realmente la riqueza de un país viene
dado por la gente que vive en este país
es decir la capacidad intelectual y la
preparación de las personas del país
cuanto más preparados estén los
habitantes de un país más capacidad de
riqueza tendrán para generar y más rico
será el país en general esto es un
criterio importantísimo porque incide en
un tema como es la educación países que
invierten en educación están invirtiendo
en su riqueza para el futuro países que
no invierten en educación están
realmente malgastando sus posibilidades
de
y progresar
vamos a ver dónde se concentra la gente
en europa porque si decimos que la
siente es un factor de gran interés
donde va a la gente
este es el mapa que nos muestra las
densidades de población en el continente
europeo me estoy centrando sobre todo en
europa porque si analizamos el mundo no
acabábamos
si analizamos si comparamos este cuadro
con el otro donde en el de la población
se ve que cuanto más oscuro más gente
vive y más y donde más amarillo menos
gente vive que vemos pues el mismo
patrón
la riqueza se concentra allí donde hay
gente
porque la riqueza la hace la gente las
zonas donde más personas vivan por lo
general en europa serán las barricas y
las zonas donde la gente no vive o se va
por la razón que sea se empobrecen
yo tengo
una serie de análisis hechos estudios y
he detectado una serie de condicionantes
de principios que nos permiten decir
bueno que hay en la base de la creación
de la riqueza una vez ya consideramos
que hay gente porque esta es la base
principal si no tenemos gente
el resto olvídate
son fáciles de retener porque todas
empiezan por ccoo además
la primera cosa necesaria es
comunicación
si tenemos gente y no saben comunicarse
entre ellos malo lo primero que tiene
que haber para que un país prospere y
una economía próspera en general es que
la gente se sepa comunicar comunicar no
significa simplemente hablar significa
también poder ir de un sitio al otro
gracias a la comunicación podemos hacer
la transmisión de conocimiento porque
esto es básico para que yo pueda mejorar
contigo tengo que expresarse decirte lo
que quiero y tú me tienes que poder
decir a mí lo que quieres ese
conocimiento no solo en la universidad
es en la vida cotidiana pero
evidentemente las universidades los
centros de enseñanza son básicos para
ello interesantísimo ver este otro
cuadro sobre la alfabetización en europa
cuando se empezó a alfabetizar europa
cuanto más oscuro antes las zonas más
oscuras en el antes de 1700 y las más
claras después posteriormente
se reconoce alguno
criterio alguna continuidad con los
cuatros anteriores pues sí evidentemente
cuando se alfabetiza la gente se puede
comunicar mejor puede transmitir
conocimiento y se generan las bases para
una riqueza futura
el segundo punto del que comentaba que
se deriva de la comunicación es el
comercio en el momento en que tenemos
capacidad de comunicar podemos comprar y
podemos vender y eso es evidentemente lo
que nos llevará a producir una riqueza
pero atención porque si tenemos
posibilidad de comunicarnos tenemos
posibilidad de transmitir conocimiento y
de comerciar pero no tenemos confianza
no vamos a hacer gran cosa la confianza
es básica la confianza es básica y la
confianza se basa en la ética yo voy a
hacer negocios contigo si confío en ti
sí sé que te voy a vender algo y me vas
a pagar si sé que pago mis impuestos y
al final voy a tener una pensión o se
van a construir infraestructuras en este
caso la sociedad evoluciona pero si no
hay confianza si la gente dice es que yo
pago impuestos y se dedican a hacer
otras cosas o la clase política está
corrupta etcétera entonces ahí se rompe
la brecha de confianza el contrato
social que une a las sociedades actuales
y por tanto ahí es donde un país entra
en declive si no hay confianza no vamos
a poder ir a ningún lado y por otro lado
la confianza nos permite colaborar
y el progreso humano es un éxito de
colaboración si no hubiéramos colaborado
los seres humanos seguiríamos cazando en
el bosque tirando piedras y poco más
donde estamos en este momento y todo lo
que podemos conseguir es gracias a la
colaboración que hemos hecho entre todos
nosotros
veamos cómo se a europa
europa es muy diversa la parte superior
de europa es llana lluviosa y fría y por
eso tiene además grandes ríos navegables
la parte inferior de europa es muy
montañosa sin ríos navegables o muy
pocos seca
que impedimentos tienen la parte del sur
de europa la comunicación todo podían
las poblaciones básicamente vivir en la
costa pero para llegar al interior era
complicadísimo mientras que en el centro
y norte de europa o en el norte de
europa sobre todo gracias a los ríos se
podía llegar a cualquier lado y si no
hubieran ríos da igual porque el todo es
llano por tanto esta comunicación en la
que estábamos hablando antes era un
factor muy fácil de conseguir en el
norte y muy difícil de conseguir en el
sur lo que explica ya en una parte
importante el porqué por ejemplo el
conocimiento se transmitió muchísimo más
rápido en el norte de europa que en el
sur porque elegir desde hamburgo a
frankfurt era muy sencillo ir desde
cualquier punto de la costa española al
interior de la península era
complicadísimo lo mismo con las
infraestructuras autopistas aves
etcétera
esto además tiene un
un efecto adicional y es que hemos dicho
que el norte de europa es frío que
significa que el norte de europa sea
frío frente al sur de europa que es
cálido en el sur de europa hambre no
tenías que pasar en cualquier época del
año básicamente a largas la mano y coges
una fruta y comes por tanto no necesitas
colaborar demasiado con nadie para
sobrevivir atrás pues te puedes plantear
solo en el norte de europa no si no
trabajas muy bien durante seis meses el
resto del año te mueres de hambre lo que
te obliga a trabajar en equipo y te
obliga a colaborar y organizarse muy
bien con el resto de la población porque
si no no sobrevives mírate este cuadro
de brueghel el viejo un pintor holandés
de mil 565 se ve perfectamente la gente
trabajando en los meses de verano el
otoño al principio de otoño en el campo
recogiendo cosechas se ven equipos de
personas y se ve un tema importantísimo
ligado también a lo que es el norte de
europa y es los suelos muy fértiles
cosa que no tenemos en el sur que los
suelos sean muy fértiles implica que las
cosechas son mucho más mayores y que las
cosechas sean mayores implica que se
pueden mantener muchas más personas que
mucha más gente puede comer con lo que
vendrá vivirá mucha más gente ahí no
tendrán que emigrar necesariamente y dar
a esa masa de personas que nos
permitirán progresar como sociedad se
transmite el conocimiento etcétera
etcétera
es decir que el vivir en el norte de
europa una vez que has organizado y la
tecnología te permite
obtener cosechas mucho más importantes
no deja de ser una grandísima ventaja
tenemos en el sur hacia los norte
europeos mejores que los europeos no
simplemente los europeos no han tenido
esa posibilidad han vivido a su ritmo
mientras que los del norte europeos
obligados por las circunstancias han
tenido que desarrollar una sociedad
donde colaboración es mucho más
importante donde la cooperación la
transmisión de conocimiento etcétera
porque es que si no se morían y se
morían y para no morir se trabajaban
durante el verano y el invierno se
podían dedicar a otros menesteres como
podría ser patinar cazar pájaros es así
es como se llama este cuadro y bueno y
estudiar porque ahí también debido a la
reforma protestante que hubo la
alfabetización llegó a todas partes y la
gente se dedicó a estudiar porque tenían
la obligación de estudiar
qué nos depara el futuro en el futuro
las fronteras físicas básicamente han
desaparecido
ya no existen esos retos insalvables
ríos sí que existen y siguen ahí pero ya
no son tan insalvables como antes y
además por la comunicación online por la
transmisión de conocimiento online
cualquier persona puede trabajar en
cualquier sitio como hemos visto antes
con otras potencias y bueno y
desarrollar su trabajo por tanto la
gente en principio puedes decir bueno
pues vamos a
a mantenernos a vivir donde sea porque
online puedo hacer lo que quiera sino la
gente va a seguir concentrándose porque
a la gente le gusta estar con otra gente
y le gusta estar donde haya citación por
tanto la transmisión del conocimiento
que decíamos antes gana en importancia y
el capital humano gana en importancia va
a ser el factor predominante ya lo es de
hecho el predominante en el futuro para
la creación de riqueza quien esté bien
preparado seguir adelante quien no lo
esté se quedará atrás y eso es aplicable
a las personas a las ciudades a las
regiones a los países los países que
pierden población pierden su futuro los
países que ganan población que retienen
el talento y que son capaces de atraer
talento de otros sitios ganan su futuro
por tanto es importantísimo que se
entienda que invertir en educación no es
un capricho es una obligación para
garantizar el futuro de cualquier país
si no tenemos una masa sólida de gente
que sepa no vamos a ir a ningún lado
entonces resumiendo hemos dicho que
necesitamos gente necesitamos
comunicación
transmisión de conocimientos comercio
confianza para colaborar y hay algo más
necesitamos algo más que ha entrado
últimamente en el juego de una forma
importantísima y es la capacidad que
tengamos en el futuro de vivir
aunando la civilización humana con el
medio y el planeta en el que estamos
estamos realmente destrozando el planeta
y si no hacemos algo para evitar esta
destrucción global no bastará no servirá
de nada que tengamos colaboración que
tengamos
confianza comercio conocimiento con la
comunicación porque nuestro futuro
entonces va a ser tan negro como está
para esta pantalla
esto tendría que ser realmente la
obligación de cualquier estado porque el
derecho a tener un país rico justo donde
toda la gente tenga un nivel de confort
necesario y además integrado dentro del
medio ambiente y en paz y en equilibrio
con la naturaleza tendría que ser
realmente la prioridad de cualquier
gobierno muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]